un tweet symbole de l'influence de
Killian Mbappé l'attaquant a été l'un
des premiers à critiquer Noël le grec
pour ses propos sur Zinédine Zidane et
beaucoup sont convaincus que c'est grâce
à lui que le président de la FFC excusé
et qu'il sera peut-être démi de ses
fonctions son message a été vu plus de
96 millions de fois comme nous la prend
cette statistique nouvelle sur Twitter
depuis l'arrivée d'Elon musk
en mai 2014 sonyasouïde est une agente
de joueurs de foot prometteuse Noël le
Gretz la contact et lui propose de
rencontrer la responsable du pôle
féminin la Fédération le rendez-vous a
lieu chez lui à son arrivée il l'attend
finalement seul une bouteille de
champagne sur la table un échange on
parle de football féminin et lors de son
rendez-vous il me dit assez clairement
que si nous étions plus proches mes
idées se concrétiseraient en tout cas il
serait beaucoup plus motivé pour pour
m'aider dans ce sens dans l'historique
de son téléphone des SMS qui prouvent
que le grec c'est finalement en écrire
contrairement à ce qu'il disait puis-je
vous inviter à dî demain soir j'insiste
et des messages vocaux encore plus
insistants
81 ans Noël le grec maîtrise bien la
technologie mais son excuse pourtant je
suis trop vieux pour ça je ne sais même
pas envoyer de SMS c'était en novembre
dernier sur RMC
personne personne n'est jamais envoyé de
SMS déplacés à des collaboratrices je
sais même pas les écrire le secret pour
séduire une fille t'intéresse j'ai passé
toute ma vie à séduire charmée draguer
les filles si j'en avais fait mon métier
je serais déjà milliardaire j'ai
toujours eu un don pour ça avec
l'expérience je suis devenu imbattable
sur le sujet j'ai passé toute ma vie à
étudier les façons de séduire une femme
ne pense pas qu'il n'y a qu'une façon de
le faire en fait tout dépend de la fille
qui lui en face de toi je suis devenu le
meilleur dans le domaine c'est pas de la
prétention c'est des faits réels bennes
recherche l'amour il est comment l'amour
pour vous alors dites-nous passer votre
annonce vous faites ce que vous voulez
mais 2m 0,5 de bonheur pour 95 kg de
tendresse voilà
2 mètres 0,5 de bonheur franchement
c'est vendeur
avant quand on en avait une grosse on
payait un impôts de solidarité
une fortune
je m'appelle Ilan m'avez surnommé le
Charo et c'était pas pour rien que la
Coupe du monde que j'ai pas soulevé
il y a que la Coupe du monde que je n'ai
pas c'est vraiment très élégant
très intéressant sur ce garçon
a révélé ce matin d'autres témoignages
recueillis par la mission d'audit menée
par le ministère des sports on y apprend
notamment que son assistante recommande
aux jeunes femmes de ne pas accepter le
rendez-vous les rendez-vous après un
déjeuner car il est souvent alcoolisé ce
qui est intéressant aussi là-dedans
c'est les excuses qui a donné Emmanuel
Macron parce que c'est excusé je pense
qu'il doit partir et Noël le
greative
laquelle lapsus
après on dira qu'il est neutre
il est objectif comme genre il y a pas
d'objectivité dans le journalisme vous
savez bien une couche de gaz
terre à 20 km d'altitude la couche
d'ozone protège notre planète des rayons
ultraviolets mais dès les années 80 un
trou est apparu au-dessus de
l'Antarctique aujourd'hui l'ONU annonce
que cette couche protectrice se
reconstitue progressivement elle devrait
être complètement reconstituée d'ici 40
ans un bel exemple d'une prise de
conscience suivie d'une coopération
internationale efficace vous savez quand
on est un tout à la maison on est un
tout on est un tout on éteint tout et
vous allez voir votre compteur
électricité et ça continue de tourner à
une vitesse dingue on se dit je crois
moi j'ai tout éteint les chargeurs
branchés par exemple et ça ça consomme
et même quand la télévision était un ne
le faites pas même quand
la petite lumière rouge oui ça consomme
en fait c'est incroyable on se rend pas
compte éteins la lumière
ça 500
et on pénètre vraiment dans Société
royale dans une intimité que normalement
on ne pénètre pas
intéressant on apprend vraiment on y
apprend vraiment plein de choses
évidemment c'est un réglement de compte
en 554 pages tout le monde l'ensemble de
la famille royale est karcher risée va
être rhabillé pour les hivers à venir
mais on y apprend quand même des choses
il y a quand même plutôt que tu es
informatique des détails qu'on avait pas
encore Babette parfois croustillant si
j'ose dire comme ce coup de froid entre
les jambes juste avant son mariage la
peur d'avoir des engelures mal placées
sur le livre mon pénis aussi est entre
extrêmement sensible et presque
traumatisé non attendez j'ai mieux que
le livre audio pour la suite
j'essayais de remettre de bonnes femmes
dont tant que m'avait recommandé une
amie la crème Elisabeth hardennes Julia
avant de commencer je tiens à vous dire
que ce soit avec vous ou bien avec
Pénélope Cruz j'adore buzzer
ne me remercier pas car grâce à ma
présence l'audience de votre matinale
vient d'atteindre celle de mon 20h le 7e
ciel et oui Laurent Delahousse 37 de le
matin c'est la température 37 2 le
machin c'est la mesure et bien faites
comme moi
ma mère se mettait ça sur les lèvres tu
veux que je m'en mette sur la [ __ ] Harry
je t'assure que ça marche j'en ai trouvé
un tube et dès que je l'ai ouvert son
parfum m'a fait remonter le temps
c'était comme si ma mère était là avec
moi dans la pièce j'en ai pris une
noisette et je l'ai appliqué
qui a théorisé
la dérive des continents
je vous donne deux noms
s'agit-il de végenais ou de Welden
[Musique]
il y avait pas il y avait pas un piège
bizarre ne rend pas justice à ce que ça
m'a fait il fallait que je vois un
médecin au plus vite mais je ne pouvais
pas demander au palais de m'en trouver
un quelqu'un à la Cour aurait eu vent de
mon problème le ferait fuiter à la
presse et hop ma [ __ ] ferait les gros
titres
[Rires]
c'est génial ici